Now that we've fixed a few problems
in the Udacity student data,
and started to uncover some
relationships between the variables,
it's time to move on to drawing
conclusions, or making predictions.
You've probably already started to
draw some tentative conclusions.
For example, that students who pass
the subway project spend more minutes in
the classroom during their first
week than students who don't.
However, even if there was no real
difference between students who passed
their project than students who didn't,
you wouldn't expect the two
means to be exactly equal.
How can you tell the difference
you saw is a true difference or
if it's due to noise in the data?
The differences we saw
looked pretty large so
it may be hard to imagine this
could be due to noise but
intuition does not always work
very well in these situations.
To rigorously check how likely it would
be to see these results by random
chance, you need to use statistics.
To learn more about how to do this,
check out Udacity statistics course
linked in the instructor notes.
For now we're not going to go further in
this direction since statistics isn't
required to take this course, but
keep in mind that the results
we have are only tentative.
They haven't been validated.